[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et tous artiste engagé
épisode 3 parties se sont engagées c'est
votre programme de rencontres digital de
la fnac qui fait se rencontrer deux
figures qui ont à coeur de mettre la
plume dans le dans le plat après l' île
à slimani et abd al malik en mars après
chloé delaume et oxmo puccino c'était en
mai on vous retrouve donc quand vous
retrouve donc en cette fin octobre avec
deux hommes jean marc jancovici et
christophe blain bonsoir messieurs vous
venez nous voir pour un livre alors je
le montre avec d'autant plus de plaisir
que j'ai appris il ya quelques instants
qui n'était pas encore paru je pensais
qu'il était paru dans ce début de
semaine mais il paraît vendredi le 29
octobre donc vous êtes les premières et
les premiers du monde à le voir derrière
la caméra mais voilà l'objet final vous
le verrez vraiment et vous pourrez le
toucher dans les fnac à partir de
vendredi mais voilà vous êtes les
premiers à l'épreuve et du monde en tout
cas qu'ils vont aussi en entendre parler
puisque c'est de ça messieurs que vous
venez vous parlez je vous présente de
manière plus complète jean marc
jancovici vous êtes ingénieur en
seigneur par l'enseignant à l'école des
mines de paris vous présidez le think
thank the shift project vous avez co
créé carbone 4 une société de conseil
qui si j'ai bien compris fait et vend
des bilans carbone aux entreprises
afin de leur permettre d'imaginer elle
même des plans d'action pour faire
baisser leurs émissions de gaz à effet
de serre vous avez participé au grenelle
de l'environnement dès les tout premiers
en 2007 avec jean louis borloo je crois
à l'époque qui était ministre de
l'environnement vous avez publié
plusieurs ouvrages plusieurs essais on
vous voit on vous entend régulièrement
dans les médias audiovisuels
récemment l'hebdomadaire l'ops disais et
écrivais de vous que vous étiez devenu
une véritable star des milieux
écologistes et il disait aussi qu'il
écrivait aussi que votre popularité
s'était encore renforcée par votre
mépris des élites c'est ce qu'ils
écrivaient donc
à l'hebdomadaire l'ops christophe
christophe blain vous êtes une des deux
seules personnes au monde par une des
seules personnes au monde à avoir obtenu
deux fois vous êtes une des seules
personnes au monde à avoir deux fois le
prix du meilleur album au festival
d'angoulême y en a pas beaucoup il ya
paru il ya mégaland soprano et art
spiegelman américain vous vous lavez
riom sattouf est rien sattouf a omis sur
ma fiche vous et merci de le rappeler
pour pour lui c'est un copain
c'est bon vous l'avez vous l'avez obtenu
en 2002 pour les amériques été le
premier volume de isaac le pirate et en
2013 pour chroniques diplomatiques
volume 2 du quai d'orsay quai d'orsay
c'est cette bd assez célèbre aussi
qu'elle avait été adapté en au cinéma
par feu bertrand tavernier c'est aussi
pour ça que je donnais à signaler cette
réalisation vous avez christophe blain
été remarqué la suite de la publication
en 1999 de réducteur de vitesse vous
vous dites ans s'est révélé aussi au
grand public en illustrant donjon potron
minet qui étaient les album scénarisé
par joann sfar et et lewis trondheim et
donc ensuite les albums solo en route
que j'ai cités ce qui fait de vous donc
une des seules personnes au monde avoir
eu qu'une fois comme votre ami riad
sattouf le prix au festival d'angoulême
donc on va reparler de cet album nous
sommes donc on arrive stream pendant une
heure sur facebook sur les pages youtube
de la fnac comme d'habitude pour cette
heure qu'on va passer ensemble vous
connaissez le principe une partie des
interviews portera sur une interview de
vous donc messieurs sur votre album et
sur son actualité la deuxième partie
sera une question des adhérentes et des
adhérents puisque des adhérentes et
adhérents se sont inscrits pour vous y
inscrire pour vous poser pour vous
défier pour vous mettre à la question et
en conclusion donc la partie habituels
sur les coups de coeur
les claques culturel de nous inviter ce
troisième numéro d'artiste vous engagez
là en cette fin octobre 2021 s'inscrit
dans un contexte qui est plurielle le
contexte électoral puisque on connaît
maintenant pratiquement toutes les
candidates et des candidats qui vont
chercher à avoir les 500 parrainages
pour être justement candidates et
candidats aux élections présidentielles
donc on note déjà des éléments de
langage sur des choses du nucléaire de
l'environnement des préoccupations
écologiques qui ont vu le jour tout ça
s'inscrit aussi dans le contexte de
hausse des prix des énergies qu'on
connaît actuellement lesquels hausse des
prix d'énergie ont engendré une hausse
des prix du gaz de l'essence même de la
baguette de pain tout ça est dû ou
justement à ces différentes hausses on
vous interrogera aussi là dessus puisque
c'est ce qui fait le contexte concrets
en termes de pouvoir d'achat en termes
de préoccupation et en termes de
structure de civilisation aussi ces
hausses des prix d'une hausse du prix
des énergies donc à l'énergie or ce
livre justement il porte sur l'énergie
et qu'est ce qu'il y a dans les énergies
quelle est l'histoire physique
financière la raison d'être des énergies
qu'elle soit carbonées non carbonées que
ce soit le charbon que ce soit le
pétrole que ce soit les résister que ce
soit le vent que ce soit clair que ce
soit les cinq éléments c'est une grande
ce livre là un monde sans fin c'est une
histoire du monde vus par justement
l'histoire le commerce de l'énergie
mais c'est aussi d'énergie des hommes
d'énergie des hommes et des femmes c'est
le travail et le travail aussi est
devenue une énergie qui se vend et elle
se vend d'autant mieux que cette énergie
peut se financer à reese est aussi si
elle elle produit du pétrole du charbon
etc et des matériaux qui dépend de tout
ça c'est l'énergie humaine c'est
l'énergie qu'on fabriquait les éléments
mais aussi les sommes que vous racontez
encore une fois de son histoire de son
invention de son essence de sa façon
d'être sa raison d'être à l'énergie
jusqu'à sa commercialisation et sa
financiarisation qui a à voir donc avec
le capitalisme lequel aussi à avoir avec
la croissance et le manque d énergie et
donc avec la façon dont le monde la
planète n'a plus d'énergie et qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour le futur ça donne donc
un monde sans fin c'est votre dialogue à
vous deux messieurs c'est ce livre qui
donc paraîtra vendredi aux éditions
dargaud alors
avant je voulais juste vous poser une
question sur cette notion de d'artistes
engagés je commence toujours comme ça
avec nos invités et vous avez choisi de
participer à ce programme en france
compte dix artistes engagés ça évoque
malraux ça évoque des intellectuels ça
évoque claudel qui était écrivain et
diplomate paul claudel ça évoque des
figures comme ça pour vous messieurs
quand on vous dit artiste engagé artiste
engagé c'est à dire quoi qu'est ce qui
vous vient à l'esprit qu'elle figure
quel concept quelle idée vous vient à
l'esprit il vaudrait mieux commencer par
christophe parce que moi je suis inscrit
sur ce plateau moi je suis un artiste
intérimaire en cdd s'est pas vraiment ma
progression actuelle
donc best-of plateau seigneur on va
profile le bébé
merci jean marc ya pas de quoi qu'est-ce
qui me vient quand on dit artiste engagé
je sais pas me souviens bien les les
artistes engagés de quand j'étais petit
''c'était qu'étaient les symboles je
sais pas jean ferrat
par exemple c'était le style symbole
avec son petit drapeau rouge vous le
chantez un peu jean ferrat pour voir
attendez je j'aime beaucoup la chanson
potemkine une espèce de lyrisme puissant
comme ça qui sort laquelle
il avait il avait une envolée lyrique
assez fort non je préfère georges
croissance il n'y a pas longtemps j'ai
vu une interview des deux oui ceux qui
datent de 69 sur li na et louise
williams le médiateur c'était jean
pierre chabrol
c'est formidable et georges brassens se
payer la tête jean ferrat mais très
gentiment et non non c'était c'était
très chouette non les artistes engagés
je sais pas je n'ai pas de
j'ai pas de symboles globale de ce que
je moi même je ne sais pas suis-je un
artiste engagé oui si avec jean-marc
quand même oui j'ai été j'ai été voir
jean marc ce que j'ai un côté 1 depuis
que je suis petit je suis un admirateur
de pierre desproges et georges brassens
mais depuis tout petit et d'autant plus
à l'adolescence et où il était vraiment
très en retrait justement des îles sont
donc à beaucoup d artistes engagés et
puis
et puis il ya
deux ans et demi je me suis dit ça
suffit ça suffit cette attitude
individualiste anarchiste
je vais voir jean marc je vais faire un
livre engagé et c'est ce que je sais ce
que j'ai fait j'ai rompu avec mon
précédent système et je suis devenu un
artiste engagé
enfin on a un artiste engagé comme on
dit non je considère que
jean marc est un maître et je suis son
padawan donc j'ai été en formation ça
c'est ça c'est une manière pas sympa de
nous rappeler que ces vieux que lui je
suis plus vieux pin
[Musique]
que vous étiez en jedi alors en
l'occurrence et patriota je suis dans ce
livre
c'est vrai je les transformer en maître
yoda un moment je le fais parler il
inverse et je le fais par les communes
oda
oui non il ya quelque chose de cet ordre
là j'ai été voir jean marc pour qu'ils
apprennent le vrai vie qui me disent
vraiment ce qui se passe
sur les conseils de mon frère oui c'est
le progrès on va on va y revenir ce que
ce que vous dites là effectivement c'est
ce que dans le prologue de l'album vous
raconter comment vous est venue singes
éminent personnel très important et
alors artistes ouvrent intellectuel
engagé que qu'est ce qui vous vient ou
qui vous vient à l'esprit jean marc
jancovici intellectuelle si vous
demandez à mes enfants je pas sûr qu'ils
sont d'accord avec vous engagez je veux
bien artistes quand j'étais petit je
savais que je faisais un dessin de
vaches sont ça ressemblait un cochon
voir une girafe donc artistes n'ont pas
vraiment
et on me demandait de me taire lors des
camps scouts tellement je chantais mal
donc non artistes malheureusement c'est
maintenant pas ma tasse de thé à mon
grand regret triste parce que tu vois un
peu envié les gens qui savaient jouer du
piano bien chanter etc ou bien dessiné
c'est malheureusement un talent que je
n'aurais jamais par contre engagé je
viens au sens où ça fait maintenant un
moment que je veux faire d'activités
enfin la sphère qui occupent meilleur
éveillé tourne autour de la question du
changement climatique donc en fait c'est
le thème qui est qui évoquait dans le
dip
est en fait ma modeste contribution à
cet ouvrage c'est que
avant cette bd
j'avais d'autres formes d'expression
pour dire à peu près la même chose à des
publics divers donc là on s'est beaucoup
inspiré d'un cours que je donne aux
mines justement
il ya un certain nombre d'image de la bd
qui sont reprises de la façon dont
j'essaye de faire passer des notions un
peu un peu complexe donc mon engagement
et celui j'aime pas trop les grands mots
enfin si on peut dire de l'urgence
climatique
et ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai
essayé de faire sous des formes diverses
depuis maintenant allez on va dire une
petite vingtaine d'années alors
justement le prologue je pense qu'on va
en voir quelques images pendant que je
parle raconte le cheminement personnel
que vous décidiez christophe blain on
est à l'été 2010 8 vous être sur la
route des vacances avec votre campagne
vous êtes vous allé vers est trop tard
ces mêmes biens on sait bien où vous
étiez à ce moment la radio annonce vous
écouter la radio qui annonce une
canicule à paris quelques temps après
donc on vous voit parler avec votre
échangé avec votre frère
c'est lui qui vous parle qui vous cite
ce nom là jean marc jancovici en vous
disant que vous devriez faire un livre
avec lui puisque ça vous préoccupe tant
la canicule de réchauffement climatique
etc ça mouline ça mouline ça mouline
vous checkez sur internet vous le
contacter peu de temps après apparemment
il vous répond c'est vrai ça peu de
temps après vous l'avez vraiment répondu
oui alors il se trouve que son frère est
par ailleurs un client
de la société dans laquelle je travaille
et donc j'avais échangé avec lui de visu
faible carbone 4 fameux carbone cap donc
le monde est petit parfois
parce que sans trahir de secrets en fait
son frère travaille dans le domaine
financier et ils essayent de faire de l'
épargne salariale vous savez de
l'épargné qui correspond à
l'intéressement que voilà qu'ils soient
orthodoxe au regard des enjeux
climatiques et donc un jour où j'ai
rencontré ou en discutaient de ce genre
de choses il a parlé de son frère alors
comme je suis un ours complet j'avais
pas fait le rapprochement immédiatement
serbe l'un pour moi je ne t'ai pas dit
immédiatement à ces le christophe blain
dont qu'il a il m'a dit j'ai un frère
qui défile avec deux fois le prix angola
sattouf
[Rires]
et donc
eux ils aimeraient éventuellement
discuter bon pourquoi pas et en fait je
sais donc on a eu un entremetteur
effectivement en l'occurrence qui était
son frère alors ce livre c'est un
à la fois un beau livre est une bande
dessinée il fait très concrètement
pratiquement 200 pages il est bourré
bourg est bourré de données
d'information de gros qui de graphiques
de statistiques tout en ayant une patte
pédagogique et une patte narrative assez
dingue parce que c'est vraiment il était
une fois pas l'histoire du monde vus par
le pétrole l'essence des énergies
carbonées leur commerce la façon dont
elle est finie en série de ces et c'est
la force de travail humaine aussi tout
ça avec une richesse aussi une
différence parfois de ton de dessin
parce que justement il ya aussi des
montres le monde et explorateur on au
moment de la préhistoire les continents
donc il ya aussi un jeu sur les ailes et
les dessins des couleurs et les façons
de graphie de fer graphie de tout de
tout ça mais moi je voudrais bien savoir
comment ce que vous avez réussi à faire
à mettre de l'ordre dans toute cette
histoire du monde parce qu'en fait c'est
un livre d'histoire c'est un cours
d'histoire qui normalement durer
peut-être normalement il ya le primaire
et le collège pour apprendre tout ça il
ya 191 pages dessinées etc avec des tas
de graphiques ça pourrait paraître
rébarbatif saleh pas du tout c'est même
des fois tout à fait cocasse
comment donc comment vous avez procédé à
la mise en ordre blanc j'ai commencé par
telle énergie je vais commencer par tel
point du monde de points d'histoire pour
mettre tout ça dans l'or ça va vraiment
de a à z c'est tout à fait clair et tout
à fait pédago alors qu'on se dise en
fait avant j'avais un compris là j'ai
l'impression art ou compliqué dans des
parties du
du du raisonnement est dû comme le
disait jean marc de son court départ qui
fait qu'un court assez impressionnant
parce que c'est un cours qui fait
environ 2h30
ou quelque chose comme ça et qui est
destiné à des élèves
futurs ingénieurs et ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que c'est un cours
qui est absolument compréhensible par
tout le monde on peut le suivre il
existe en ligne et secours on comprend
tout c'est ce qui a servi de base
d'introduction libre et ensuite alors
moi j'ai au départ j'ai demandé à jean
marc parce que j'avais besoin de moi
j'ai besoin qu'on me parle j'ai besoin
que les gens soient là un vrai qu'ils
existent j'avais besoin d'un contact je
voulais pas à prendre de choses à vendre
alors évidemment mon frère lui suivait
les conférences de jean marc depuis déjà
une dizaine d'années et il manque à mon
client parce que je vois le vol votre
faire le fameux client c'est mon client
mais il n'y a pas il n'a pas fait ça
pour rien c'est à dire qu'il a il s'est
engagé professionnellement parce que je
pense il à jean marc lui il ya eu ni
l'humiliation il a compris ce qui se
passait et il a eu envie de me dessiner
en vierge n'a pas destiné aux vierges je
jetais des confusions personnages plus
ou moins engagés à verser
comme ici qui demande en direct la
dessiner en vierge sur une prochaine
édition used as tu
sais je pense sera peut-être pour un
autre tour mais
oui donc en fait je savais un peu qu'il
était jean marc mais moi j'aime quand je
rencontre les gens ne pas savoir de
choses sur eux pour avoir une espèce de
fraîcheur et de et de
c'est le contact qui va me dire c'est ce
qu'ils vont me dire c'est que je vais
l'écouter écoutez j'ai besoin d'entendre
leur voix la façon dont ils parlent
qu'ils sont même physiquement et alors
il trouve quand même qu'avant d'aller
voir jean marc j'ai regardé quelques
quelques conférences sur sur internet je
ne voulais pas le faire avant parce que
je faisais un déni ça me faisait très
peur le climat etc et je trouve que
effectivement en 2018 a été une année
charnière
est ce que c'est la prom' c'est là moi
j'entendais parler de ces problèmes
depuis pas mal de temps on a
l'impression on a le sentiment que
maintenant c'est des choses qui sont
vraiment acquise de parler du changement
climatique or c'est très récent c'est à
dire que avant cette année 2018 dans les
grands médias
traditionnels de grande diffusion on en
parlait pas comme c'était pas un titre
du journal c'était des articles
dans des revues annexes ou enfin c'était
pas c'était pas là il ya une canicule et
skate vous citiez que j'étais en
normandie cnce moi je me rendais pas
compte de la canicule à ce moment là
parce que c'est un endroit où la
canicule n'avait pas d'effet elle était
à paris et j'ai vu des gens qui
écrivaient qu'ils mettaient
immédiatement relations et notamment un
article de jean jouzel que je qui est un
climat glaciologue qui grâce à la
glaciologie étudie le climat parce qu'il
est pas climatologue et glaciologue
à l'origine je me trompe pas j'emprunte
jeu quand je dis je donne d'informations
plus ou moins scientifiques que j'ai
besoin
scientifique donc voilà donc et là j'ai
eu une espèce de choc parce que je me
suis dit cette chose que je remettais
devant parce qu'on dise et les
générations futures c'est il faut
laisser quelque chose à nos enfants non
non non c'est nous c'est nous maintenant
ça commence maintenant parce que jean
jouzel et je le cite disait dans un je
crois pour le dire c'était dans le
magazine 20 minutes donc quelque chose
de très grande diffusion disait il
donnait des idées de température qui
pourrait
exister à paris en 2050
2050 c'est dans 30 ans donne et entière
de température absolument instinct four
quoi paris devenu un fourre parler de 50
degrés mais ce n'est pas ça n'est pas
arrivé évidemment d'un coup en 2050
quelle température en 2040 2030 2020
c'est là la progression elle est
progressivement rentré dans ce four est
assez rapidement et déjà connaître
bien avant 2050 des températures très
difficile à vivre et qui vont vraiment
nous déstabiliser et pas seulement des
régions tempérées des voilà donc samassa
ma bouche et ça m'a donné que si je fais
une énorme crise d'angoissé
je ne suis pas complètement sorti j'ai
voulu faire une espèce de thérapie en
allant au coeur du sujet en rencontrant
jean marc et en voulant faire ce livre
mon frère me l'a dit m'a dit mais fait
un livre il a vu que j'étais en voici le
dit fait un livre avec jean marc
jancovici en fait j'avais pensé je
redoutais un peu l'idée j'y avais pensé
et en fait ça la réflexion moment il l'a
dit je je je crois qu'il ya eu trente
secondes de silence a qui sont
difficiles à définir dans le dans le
livre je montre du silence le temps de
la bande dessinée n'est pas le temps
réel et je me suis levé immédiatement je
dis oui je fais ce livre est là la
machine était après même mon écriture
suivante c'était que jean-marc me
répondre justement jean marc jancovici
quand un illustrateur vient à vous
trouvez vous convainc j'ai passé assez
durs ou pas est-ce que pour vous c'est
aussi une manière de d'aller trouver
gratter concerner d'autres publics que
ce que vous aviez déjà par vos
interventions dans les médias par vos
entreprises et par vaux cours est-ce que
c'était aussi pour accroître à grandir
parce que l'urgence est là les
publics et donc teintée d signale
signaux d'alarmé la réponse est oui en
fait j'avais déjà pensé depuis longtemps
a essayé de me marier entre guillemets
avec 1
des gens dans la fiction pour être
capable d'aller d'aller s'inviter sur
des terrains des gens qui lisent pas
d'essai qui ne regardent pas de vidéo
sur internet mais qui par contre peuvent
regarder une série regarder un film ou
lire une bd alors en fait la réponse à
la question qui est pourquoi ce que
c'est aussi bien rangé parce que ça m'a
pris 15 ans donc en fait au moment où
christophe découvre mon cours ça fait 15
ans que je fais des interventions et que
je me dis tiens je devrais mettre les
trucs dentelle sens sinon je devrais les
mettre dans telle autre puis non je dois
les mettre dans telle autre puis
finalement c'est un tel autre que ça va
être serré comme une pile de linge et
puis vous mettez des siècles avant de
finir par trouver que c'est bien rangés
comme ça et pas autrement donc voilà
c'est exactement pareil donc ça m'avait
pris quelques quelques années avant sur
la partie bd donc j'ai hésité à peu près
une demi seconde quand j'ai reçu son
message
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que le
sujet enfin l'idée me plaisait l'idée
d'aller m'inviter c'est quand même un
peu le début de la fiction bd c'est à
dire que on est on est très libre on
peut mettre en scène des personnages
comme on le veut on peut raconter ce
qu'on veut on peut se fiche de nous même
ce qu'on fait d'abondance autant qu'on
veut on peut illustrer des choses
imaginaire très facile donc c est un
mode d'expression qui permet d'aller
chercher des gens qu'on n'irait pas
chercher avec un essai je sais pas ce
que j'en ai fait quelques uns avant et
qu'on irait probablement pas chercher
avec une intervention parce qu'il
fallait
c'est un mode d'expression par le via
certaines personnes vont à d'autres
et puis par ailleurs
donc je redis au début j'avais pas fait
immédiatement le lien avec le frère je
faire et puis quand j'ai compris qu'il y
avait à faire j'ai hésité ou une demi
seconde à peu près alors pour lier ce
livre qui donc paraîtra le 29 octobre
dans dans deux jours et qui donc
paraîtra dans le contexte pré-électoral
que je citais en introduction de
l'émission dans le contexte aussi de
cette fameuse es et s était pas du tout
anticipé il aurait dû sortir ya un an
pour compléter ce que disait jean marc
tout à l'heure c'est que
pour l'avoir expérimenté
pour l'avoir expérimenté moi même et
pour l'avoir
en avoir été témoin aussi les gens qui
découvrent son sa pensée généralement
ils le découvrent par le biais de
conférences où ils ont été spectateur
lifeguard
terre encore il ya peu de temps je crois
jean marc jancovici et d'arbres voilà on
vous en faisait quand même quelqu'un
qu'on entend est généralement ce qui se
passe c'est que les gens sont saisis
c'est à dire que le réseau l'on vous
présente jean marc présente des choses
qui ont l'air assez complexe et qui
immédiatement sans totalement lumineuse
et il ya effectivement comme vous le
disiez beaucoup d'informations qui
s'enchaînent avec une logique absolument
implacable et qui sont qui nous qui sont
vraiment on a vraiment l'impression de
comprendre comment le monde fonctionne
c'est de la vulgarisation scientifique
et la grande frustration qu'on a c'est
qu'évidemment quand on a on a on a reçu
un tel enseignement même si c'est une
conférence tu as des conférences qui
sont plus ou moins
il ya le cours des mines puis des fois
tu es tu étais capable de la concentrer
en trois quarts d'heure ou en 1h enfin
bon on a envie de la transmettre c'est à
dire qu'on a envie de le raconter à
d'autres gens alors on il ya quelques
éléments sur lesquels on arrive à
s'accrocher et puis très rapidement on
peut pas parce qu'on peut pas son
raisonnement est temps c'est trop
difficile de le reprendre et ce livre
c'était moi j'ai ça m'est déjà arrivé
dans les dîners d'essayer d'expliquer
des choses aux gens oui vous comprenez
le pétrole parce que les énergies
dites renouvelables etc etc et puis il
ya un moment je suis perdu je n'arrive
pas et c'était une manière c'était une
manière aussi de transmettre ça c'est à
dire que ça devient quelque chose qu'on
peut saisir qu'on peut lire de manière
ludique auquel on peut se référer et
qu'on peut qu'on peut rire c'est que on
a envie de on a souvent on écoute une
conférence de jean marc on a envie de la
transmettre c'est une manière de la
transmettre et moi c'était une manière
aussi pour moi de m'imprégner de son de
son raisonnement et de est 2e et de le
transmettre je précise que c'est pas
quelque chose de son c'est quelque chose
qui est alarmant mais qui n'est pas
forcément
alarmistes qui est engagée ou engageant
et qui est pédago c'est pas quelque
chose dont on sort complètement déprimé
on ressort plus saisis c'était pour être
plus pour exciter le leu leu leu
j'imagine le côté volontaire voire
engager justement chez le lecteur ou la
lectrice m'enfin y'a rien de de
déprimant ce qui va ce qui pourrait
déprimer c'est de se dire après bon bah
je sais pas comment faire au contraire
vous vous proposez pas des pistes mais
enfin vous proposer de là où pourraient
être les pistes ce long terme je crois
qu'on est la révélation d'un don il a
fallu six à la fois lucide et ludique on
présente le livre de manière ludique et
lucide
parce qu'on est comme ça parce que jean
marc est comme ça il a une façon de
raconter les choses un vrai conteur en
fait et c'est pour ça qu'il tombe bien
aussi le livre parce que mine de rien il
paraît dans le comté ce que disait donc
tu as de la hausse des prix là ce matin
sa part c'était la roue de la baguette
de pain depuis deux semaines c'est la
hausse du prix l'essence dont on ne sait
pas comment ça va rester arrêté parce
que c'est dû à la fois la raréfaction
l'augmentation des coûts de production
de voyages etc
le
la grande réunion créé par le siècle de
la coop 26 à glasgow démarre dans deux
semaines maintenant donc l'environnement
la halle à l'envi de solutions et
l'urgence de solutions climatiques de
trouver comment ce qu'on pourrait
inventer créer financer produire et
faire accepter une ou des énergies
décarbonées renouvelables ou pas c'est
ça qui va qui va gouverner nos vies
pendant les années à venir et qui va
gouverner en tout cas les informations
d'ici la présidentielle votre ouvrage
paraît aussi dans ce contexte là
commence que justement vous entendez jeu
là alain comeau peut-être commençons par
jean marc jancovici le contexte actuel
justement au niveau des cours du gaz du
pétrole des céréales de l'électricité on
lit dans la presse encore ce mardi matin
que l'électricité du tir et du charbon
est plébiscitée par de nombreux états
car moins chères que celles produites
par d'autres énergies faut-il c'était
libération ce matin une crise basée sur
les prix d'énergie donc et sur le manque
pour les remplacer qu'est ce que ça vous
évoque sa et qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de tirer comme signal d'alarmé que
vous n'auriez éventuellement pas encore
tiré pourtant kahn a beaucoup
si je peux être un peu taquin
san est une surprise que par les gens
qui n'ont pas lu pour les gens qui n'ont
pas lu cette excellente ouvrage en fait
ce qu'on essaye d'expliquer dans ce jeu
vous rappelle qu'ils aient pas encore
paru dont personne n'a encore vu non
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que ça n'est malheureusement une
surprise que pour des gens qui vont
découvrir à cette occasion
qu'il ya un gros malentendu en ce qui
concerne l'énergie c'est qu'elle a
totalement structurer le monde moderne
et que pourtant la façon dont on s'en
sert aujourd'hui ne peut pas durer et à
partir du moment où ça ne peut pas durer
c'est qu'il se passe des choses
désagréables
qui se manifeste de façon de plus en
plus fréquentes si on ne change pas de
nous mêmes le sujet alors anticiper
l'avenir est un truc qui est toujours un
peu pénible pour nous parce que le long
terme sébacées loin quoi donc voilà je
faisais la réflexion n'y a pas longtemps
de savoir quelle fraction des gens
paieraient une assurance contre les
incendies pour leur logement si ce
n'était pas obligatoire
et malheur ça n'arrive qu'aux autres et
donc là on est typiquement face à un
problème ou tant qu'il n'est pas là en
fait essayer de faire comprendre qu'il
va arriver et qu'il faut faire beaucoup
d'efforts pour qu'il n'arrive pas c'est
quelque chose qui est compliqué alors
quand le problème arrive de quelle
manière ils arrivent c'est aussi ce
qu'on a essayé d'expliquer dans ce livre
en fait ils arrivent justement avec des
variations de prix il arrive avec des la
dépression économique ça c'est pour la
partie énergie et puis il arrive
également avec des ennuis climatique
dont christophe a parlé de la canicule
de 2018 a pas eu celle de 2019 après
enfin voilà ça là l'été dernier on a eu
beaucoup de chance en france les
canadiens n'ont pas eu autant de chance
des sibériens n'ont pas eu autant de
chance les grecs n'ont pas eu autant de
chance lecture qui n'ont pas eu autant
de chance marocains n'ont pas eu autant
de chance des algériens enfin il ya eu
beaucoup de gens comptent pas beaucoup
de chance il ya une au milieu mais voilà
donc le donc les ennuis maintenant ils
sont là alors qu'est-ce que ça m'inspire
la hausse des prix tout et rien c'est à
dire qu'à partir du moment où les ennuis
ce qu'on se connaissait aussi
d'expliquer c'est que tout ça est une
structuration tellement puissante ce qui
s'est passé avec l'avènement des
machines parce que l'énergie si
l'avènement des machines que au moment
où les environnements sont là il n'y a
pas de solution magique presse-bouton
pour se débarrasser des ennuis c'est
justement pour ça qu'il faut anticiper
encore une fois quand ça vous tombe
dessus vous pouvez plus rien faire et
avoir des regrets ne vous sert pas à
grand chose
au moment où vous avez un nouveau deux
poumons qui s'en va parce que vous avez
fumé trop longtemps peux vous dire vous
auriez pas du oui certes mais à ce
moment là vous pouvez plus éviter les
emmerdements balasse voilà donc la
hausse des prix elle et c'est un cetain
c'est un petit coup de réveil matin
pour nous rappeler que on reste
dépendant à un système sur lequel on n'a
pas fait beaucoup d'efforts pour en
sortir alors c'est dur d'en sortir
du reste on a mis cette couverture-là
couleurs d'un célèbre gillet
c'est dur de s'en sortir on annoncé
c'est dur de s'en sortir et c'est
justement parce que c'est dur de s'en
sortir que ça demande une concertation
importante que ça demande un plan
quelque chose qui soit planifiée sur le
long terme parce qu'en général quand
c'est dur il faut échéance et l'effort
et que sa demande surtout un constat
partagé sur le problème à traiter est
aujourd'hui malheureusement
christophe disait qu'on entend beaucoup
parler du problème dans les médias
malheureusement on en entend pas
nécessairement mieux parler vous savez
c'est très facile d'entendre très
souvent parlé d'un problème est de
toujours pas comprendre comment ils se
présentent pour autant mais vous qui est
réputé avoir à leurs achats à la fois
par the shift project est à la fois par
44 à voir d'une part conseillé des
entrepreneurs ou les entreprises
carbone4 avoir l'oreille dit on 1 2
theater députés du gouvernement vous
avez quand même participé à plusieurs
grenelle de l'environnement j'imagine
qu'à des coptes 21 25 26 vous y avez été
plusieurs fois qu'est ce que vous leur
dites à celles et ceux dont on dit que
vous avez vous avez l'oreille juste ça
sert pas à grand chose de leur dire quoi
que ce soit c'est peut-être vous est
donné
il ya une expression j'aime bien qui
consiste à dire la démocratie est un
système remontant
alors ça veut dire quoi que c'est un
système remontant ça veut dire que les
élus y bouge quand la base bouge en fait
vous savez les élus c'est un très bon
reflet de leur flash pas des élus
nationaux c'est un très bon reflet de
l'opinion avec 3 en décalage les élus
locaux sont un très bon reflet de
l'opinion avec six mois de décalage
c'est plus court ce qui veut dire qu'en
fait au niveau des élus nationaux ça ne
sert strictement à rien alors j'ai fini
par comprendre ça après avoir eu
quelques cheveux blancs ça ne sert à
rien d'aller les voir en leur expliquant
qu'on a une bonne idée ça ne sert à rien
les élus vous les intéressés à partir du
moment où vous avez le problème la
solution au problème et la sanction si
jamais il n'applique pas la solution au
problème donc vous n'intéressez les élus
que si vous avez un pouvoir de nuisance
c'est à dire si vous êtes capable de
mobiliser à leur détriment une partie de
leurs électeurs voilà là vous commencez
à les intéresser tant vous en êtes pas
là c'est bull à vous laver c'est juste
pas non c'est juste pas la peine de
céder juste pas la peine d'aller les
voir
alors je commence enfin jeu l'équipe du
chiffre project beaucoup plus large que
moi commence à exister un peu aux yeux
de ces gens là veulent dire comme ça
j'espère que ce bouquin c'est en ça que
j'accepte l'étiquette d'engager va
amener un nombre non négligeable
d'électeurs supplémentaires
à être un peu saisis comme disait
christophe tout à l'heure effectivement
et a commencé à vouloir s'intéresser
plus au problème est donc forcé les élus
s'intéressent à veut dire quoi forcer
les élus à s'intéresser au problème
dire que la hiérarchie change
aujourd'hui on est dans un monde dans
lequel en gros la hiérarchie c'est
d'abord on s'occupe du truc important
que j'appelle l'économie et ensuite s'il
reste de la place on va essayer de faire
ça le moins mal possible pour
l'environnement tant qu'on aura cet
ordre de priorité
c'est malheureusement des limitations
involontaire alors l'augmentation du
prix pour le moment c'est très très doux
comme l'imitation involontaire on aura
pire que ça qu'ils vont chargé de régler
le problème
pour que ça soit nous qui nous chargions
de régler le problème il faut que la
hiérarchie change
pour le moment on n'en est pas là la
majeure partie des électeurs ne sont pas
là et donc la quasi totalité des élus
n'en sont pas là non plus pour finir sur
la partie interview avant d'en venir aux
questions des adhérents et wade rente
qui dont certaines concernent aussi à
ses engagements c'est pour ça qu'il ya
des questions que je peux je pose pas il
ya un concept un moment s'est ouvert le
troisième tiers du livre c'est le
concept d'énergie contraintes qui
rappelle aussi le concept de
décroissance et serra il est dit alors
les deux narrateur du livre c'est vous
2-1 christophe blain dessinant gros
souvent des conversations et des mises
en scène des mises en abyme qui sont
entre vous deux qui donnent le côté
ludique et ce qui doit aussi le côté il
était une fois à ce livre qui encore une
fois est aussi une histoire c'est notre
histoire c'est l'histoire de ce avec
quoi nous avons fabriqué notre force de
travail nos énergies nos décors nos
produits la société de consommation mais
c'est notre histoire et donc à un moment
ce concept d'énergie contrainte ou un
moment les deux narrateurs que vous êtes
10 il va falloir accepter de deux
puisqu'on met de plus en plus dans le
monde de plus en plus 2 du main avec de
moins en moins de place puisque les clés
des réfugiés climatiques vont faire que
y'aura plus en plus de monde en même
temps droit et de prendre le pas sur le
continent les la fonte des glaces etc le
rétrécissement des continents et il va
falloir accepter d'avoir
autant d'énergie que maintenant mais
pour plus de monde donc moins d'énergie
chacun donc s'habituer à moins consommer
à ne se nourrir différemment ou à moins
se nourrir bref et puis comme ça on aura
besoin de moins d'énergie moins
consommera moins on aura besoin d'avoir
des produits qu'on va acheter donc moi
on aura besoin qu'il soit fabriqué mon
coup on aura besoin de produire donc
moins on aura besoin d'énergie pour les
produire beaucoup moins peut-être on
aura besoin d'énergie tout court ce
concept d'énergie contraintes qu'on
n'entend pas là dans les éléments de
langage de celles et ceux qui veulent
être candidats pour le moment la
présidentielle qui est comment ils
pourraient être imposées pas ce qui va
avec le phénomène de décroissance alors
faut déjà être à la base d'accords
éventuellement politiquement avec ce
concept de décroissance des industriels
des capitalistes ils vont pas être
d'accord avec le concept de décroissance
évidemment mais ce concept d'économie
d'énergie contraintes de même que vous
développiez un peu parce que là pour le
coup il peut y avoir une solution c'est
en tournant
maintenant là ça serait trop risqué non
c'est jean-marc l' agent m'a parlé c'est
le maître qui part
c'est un des concepts qu'avant ce livre
et qui entre en résonance avec le côté
lorsqu'on est connu pour moment devant
tout ce qu'on sait qu'on va sens ce
qu'on explique à un moment c'est que
alors l'énergie qu'on eut alors quand je
compose quand je dis qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui il ya quand même un énorme
développement dans le livre pour
expliquer que l'on en fait c'est pas
nous c'est des machines peut utiliser de
l'énergie c'est utiliser des machines
que utiliser plus d'énergie c'est
utiliser plus de machines c'est avoir
plus d'esclaves mécanique à son service
c'est ça le utiliser plus d'énergie
et la contrainte elle est double en fait
d'une part elle vient du fait que
l'essentiel de la nourriture qu'on donne
à nos machines sort du sous sol c'est ce
qu'on appelle les combustibles fossiles
donc au lieu d'ouvrir le placard pour
sortir les croquettes pour le chat nous
on ouvre le sous sol pour sortir des
croquettes pour machines savoir du
charbon du pétrole et du gaz et
troisième personnage du livre iron man
qui justement qui symbolise à lui seul
toutes les machines vient là plein de
personnages dans le livre mais celui là
effectivement éteint est en fait c'est
un personnage que j'avais utilisé pour
mes cours justement pour faire
comprendre la notion d' exosquelette qui
est constituée par toutes les machines
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui de la machine
à laver jusqu'à l'ascenseur en passant
par le laminoir et le camion de 40
tonnes tout ça c'était un bouddhiste
d'exosquelette c'est un bouddha et
rodman
et donc cette nourriture pour iron man
elle est essentiellement fossiles et le
dictionnaire là en l'occurrence et bien
fait ces fossiles parce que ça date d'il
ya très longtemps et que ça a mis très
longtemps à se former et donc comme ça
date d'il ya très longtemps et que servi
très longtemps à se former on peut pas
en avoir de plus en plus pour la nuit
des temps on peut même pas en avoir
autant pour la nuit des temps est en
fait la contrainte vient de là vient du
fait que les réservoirs se vide donc il
ya tout un passage où on explique par
exemple que la découverte du pétrole
c'est comme la chasse aux oeufs de
pâques d'abord on trouve ce qui est gros
et mal cachée et puis tout à fait à la
fin on trouve ce qui est petit est bien
planqués et évidemment ce qui se vident
beaucoup plus vite et ce qui coûte
beaucoup plus cher à exploiter la bonne
route dans
donc les donc ces énergies on va être
contraint par le fait que c'est pas
possible d'en recréer au fur et à mesure
qu'on s'en sert
et il ya une deuxième et ça représente
une telle fraction de l'énergie qu'on
utilise qu' on ne peut pas imaginer
remplacer sa part autre chose un pour un
voilà c'est aussi un développement qu'on
fait dans le dos et puis il ya une
deuxième contrainte c'est que iron man
quand il a mangé ses croquettes il
respire du co2 donc ça il évacue du co2
c'est les fameux gaz à effet de serre
qui sont émis par les machines que nous
utilisons et puis marginalement par
d'autres procédés bien enfin marginal
pas tant que ça mais par le procédé est
donc ça c'est une deuxième limite au
sens où à un moment ou un autre le
changement climatique va devenir
suffisamment ample pour que à lui tout
seul il est la capacité à ne pas nous
permettre de garder des sociétés stables
et prospères là où ça fait dix mille ans
qu elles sont implantées il faut
rappeler que ça fait dix mille ans que
le climat était stable et que c'est
grâce à ça que les civilisations
sédentaires ont pu émerger et se
perfectionner au fil du temps avec des
éléments qui ne variait pas ce qui a
permis aux hommes et aux femmes à une
époque on était beaucoup plus vulnérable
d'avoir le temps pour nous est de
perfectionner les techniques jusqu'à
l'époque actuelle où on est devenu
beaucoup plus invulnérable donc ironman
il a aussi cette caractéristique de nous
permettre de résister à des tops
perturbations la canicule qu'on a eu il
ya quelques années dans un monde sans
énergie elles auraient fait des
centaines de milliers de morts bon là on
a eu un monde avec énergie donc elle a
tué trente mille vieux pas très grave
encore une fois on aura pire m'est donc
il faut bien voir que on a on a
constitué grâce à l'énergie une capacité
à s'abstraire des variations des
éléments mais qui est transitoire
malheureusement donc c'est ça la
contrainte qu'on évoque c'est le fait
que en fait que costume d'iron man si je
peux prendre ce parallèle un peu se
rétrécir avec le temps et se rétrécir de
plus en plus et puis voilà et qu'il va
falloir qu'on compose avec ça
alors on va maintenant passer il est 19
heures 39 aux questions des adhérentes
et des adhérents toujours sur ce
troisième numéro d'artiste engagé avec
jean marc jancovici et christophe blain
alors certaines on va commencer par des
questions qui sont sur votre état
d'esprit alors là c'est des questions
sur vous deux après justement cet album
et c'est une question qui vient entre
autres de stéphanie qu'à la belgique de
courbevoie dans les hauts-de-seine quel
est votre état d'esprit messieurs quel
est votre état d'esprit après cet
ouvrage est tout ce qu'il vous a appris
ben je pense que je marque et le même
état d'esprit parce qu'il a fait état
d'esprit deux filles ses victimes est
ce que est ce que j'ai changé ou en fait
ce jugement je ne
fais qu tivement je ne suis plus le même
je ne suis plus ce que je ne sais plus
celui que j'étais avant de faire là bas
non mais ça a l'air bizarre mais c'est
comme quand on a des enfants on se
rappelle plus ce que c'était quand on en
avait pas ou deux il ya des tas de
choses dans la vie comme ça c'est un
exemple voilà je me rappelle plus
exactement ce que j' étais avant cet
album
je le retrouve plus et c'est difficile
de dire exactement quelle est mon état
d'esprit c'est un c c'est un mélange
alors il ya c'est un album la
fabrication de cet album est quelque
chose qui me j'en suis pas assorti il ya
une partie de moi qui va en sortir quand
l'album sortira justement ce qu'il y
aura une transmission qui sera fait pour
l'instant c'est difficile à décrire mais
j'ai l'impression de garder encore des
choses j'ai besoin d'avoir des réactions
de lectrices de lecteurs et 2 et 2
j'ai besoin de ça pour l'instant je suis
encore je pourrais dire encore un peu
oppressé de tout ce que j'ai tout le
travail qu'on a fait jean marc et moi
dedans est tout ce que j'ai pu tout ce
que j'ai pu apprendre
alors les choses et je les savais déjà
avant de ravager avait compris le
principe avant de mai avant d'aller voir
jean marc mais ce que j'en apprends tous
les jours parce qu'en fait
l'apprentissage il est permanent ou
jean-marc m'apprend des nouvelles plus
ou moins terrible plus ou moins
engageante plus ou moins qui donne la
mesure des choses
qui sont étonnantes à chaque fois je le
rencontre parce qu'il travaille il est
tout le temps dedans il est en mouvement
permanent
dont qui connaît cette marche du monde
auquel il est on est en confrontation
moi j'en suis un peu en retrait je suis
un dessinateur je suis un scénariste et
gégé une activité qui est assez tient un
peu asocial qui dépend complètement de
la société mais mais en même temps je
suis je suis un peu retranché avec lui
je fais je me fais un bain de réalité de
très puissant même parfois assez violent
sur la façon dont les choses
fonctionnent et j'ai plus je ne peux
plus avoir le même regard sur les choses
je vois la valeur de quand on parle du
costume d'iron man on est dedans là nous
sommes entourés de machines nous
communiquons avec des gens qui ne nous
voit pas ça qui nous voient mais qui ne
sont pas avec nous c'est une partie du
des super pouvoirs de l'exosquelette et
on s'en rend même pas compte ça fait
partie de notre de notre environnement
naturel notre corps notre cerveau est
complètement habitué à ça comme d'un an
vers un environnement complètement
naturel et or ça n'est pas assez c'est
un environnement naturel qui ne
qui ne fonctionne pas comme une forêt
qui se renouvellent elle même qui a sa
propre vie auquel elle a qu'un homme
fait partie c'est quelque chose qui
puise dans des réserves c'est quelque
chose et on se rend pas compte on a on a
beaucoup de mal en tant qu'être humain
en tant que personne à le percevoir ça
va être des éléments extérieurs
certainement perturbant qui vont nous en
donner la valeur qui vont être des
pénuries
complètement imprévue un climat
extrêmement difficile à vivre des
mouvements de population
détention etc et
c'est vrai que ça fait ça fait craindre
mais ça forge aussi une certaine
philosophie que j'ai appris auprès de
jean marc qui est de ne pas forcément
évidemment la première question c'est
quelles sont les solutions en fait
l'acteur il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de
solution globale
il n'y a pas de solution globale et
mathématiques qui est rassurante une
fois pour toutes
on est on est des êtres en mouvement qui
qui évolue en permanence et les
solutions en réalité on va les trouver
en se mettant en mouvement en étant
confronté aux éléments
le but est de se mettre en mouvement le
plus rapidement possible essayez
d'anticiper le plus possible il faut
commencer par faire un pas un autre
c'est l'image qu'on a mis dans le livre
qui vient de
[Musique]
d2 l'enseignement de jean marc qui il
faut pas regarder ce qui a tout en haut
il est con ce qu'on doit obtenir pour
que ce soit parfait il faut voir les
marches il faut monter les marches les
unes après les autres il faut savoir
être patient il faut savoir dépasser
sa peur et faire ce qu'on peut faire à
sa propre échelle à accepter aussi ses
limites qu'on n'est pas omniscient nous
ne peut pas tout faire faut accepter
qu'il ya des choses sur lesquelles on
n'a pas prise mais qu'en même temps je
crois qu'à partir du moment où on a
conscience de ces choses là on est déjà
en mouvement on est déjà en train de
faire quelque chose même si on n'a pas
l'impression parce que le la réflexion
le regard qu'on a sur le mont ne peut
plus être le même et que de toute façon
va se
on est en train de se programmer même
sans le savoir profondément pour
progressivement agir différemment et
évoluer
progresser dans cet effet rappelle
jean-marc le fait beaucoup fait rappelle
aussi aux jeunes générations c'est les
jeunes générations qui vont prendre ce
relais qui vont devoir faire des choix
mais nous aussi on est tous les deux des
quinquagénaires mais on est on est
concerné directement des changements
brutaux on est appelé à les connaître
deuxième question qui va justement être
à la fois pour l'illustrateur et le
chercheur est
essayiste
question d' eric provost est ce qu'une
bd engagée peut avoir autant ou plus
d'impact qu'un roman
ça se pose là parce que vous avez choisi
l'illustration
mais aussi de raconter une histoire ça
va poser la question suivante
non mais je peux dire quelque chose à
savoir n'a pas à un roman c'est une
fiction
or là on ne raconte il n'y a pas de
fichier jean marc m'avait dit pourquoi
il m'avait posé la question pourquoi ne
pas faire une fiction fait une fiction
on complexifie le problème parce que la
fiction c'est un monde en soi c'est un
travail en soi de créer un monde
cohérent et c'est pas forcément en fait
tous les éléments étaient déjà là
l'histoire était déjà là et ce qui nous
a permis d'avoir jean-marc quand il
racontait avec un talent extraordinaire
qui est l'image analogique c'est à dire
qu'il fait des analogies sur des
concepts qui peuvent être complexes
immédiatement il alors par exemple la
caricature qu'on fait d' iron man c'est
bon l'exosquelette qui est très simple
il y en a plein d'autres et moi aussi je
veux que généralement quand on
m'explique un concept j'ai envie de le
mettre en image et que cette image ou
d'un an elle devient un personnage on
parle d on parle de la façon dont
fonctionnent les technocrates par
exemple alors quel technocrate à quel
niveau que ce soit des technocrates
européens que ce soit des économistes
que ce soit des observateurs ils
deviennent des personnages des
personnages c'est des petits personnages
myope parce qu'ils n'ont pas une vision
à long terme donc ils font de gros sacs
sont des petites femmes pour les dix
hommes qui sont comme ça est qui et qui
sont en contact avec des phénomènes qui
sont beaucoup plus grands que alors
qu'ils ont l'impression de de tenir les
clés du monde en parlant de croissance à
tout bout de champ ça nous permet de
créer des images qui ont un côté très
ludique même comique mais en même temps
qui permette d'expliquer des choses
complexes immédiatement on voit à quoi
ça correspond on voit qu'on comprend
comment se forme le pétrole tout est
imagé
ce fameux co2 dont on parle qui n'est ni
bon ni mauvais parce qu'il nous permet
de nous permet aussi de vivre il retire
la chaleur sur la terre permise ou alors
après il est question d'excès il ya des
questions de voilà donc les les à chaque
chaque chaque élément devient une
histoire
des histoires qui peuvent être d'ordre
sociétal qui peuvent être d'ordre de la
vulgarisation scientifique physique on a
raconté un certain de l'histoire et avec
des images l'image permet de d'avoir une
vision parfois immédiate du concept même
sens les mots et de s'appuyer dessus et
de jouer avec d'être spectaculaire
d'être d'être drôle d'être le plus
ludique possible et les gens remarque m
il me servait ça sur un plateau parce
que lui même dans ses conférences
utilise beaucoup d'imagés pour faire
comprendre il arrive à faire comprendre
et parfois quand je comprenais pas
quelque chose il me donnait une première
image si elle fonctionnait pas la
deuxième ou la troisième était
immédiatement lumineuse et je
l'utilisais tout de suite juste que tu
as dit c'est génial je le représente tel
que qui me l'a dit quoi donc ça c'est
effectivement un pouvoir de
l'illustration donc bande dessinée pour
mais toutes façons l'option roman elle
était pas nécessairement ouverte moi je
m'imagine pas comme romancier
le donc moi j'ai répondu scolairement la
question si la question avait eu plus
d'impact j'en sais rien il faudra
essayer de là on a juste essayé une
version on espère que cette version là
va avoir de l'impact voilà c'est clair
qu'un roman ça désincarné un peu plus le
problème parce que le lecteur ne sait
pas nécessairement ce qui relève de la
fiction et ce qui relève de la partie
documentaire
donc en cela je pense que christophe a
eu parfaitement raison de dire il faut
pas y aller trop loin dans le côté
fiction parce que finalement à un moment
on croit rendre service en rendant le
propos goût plus beaucoup plus digeste
parce qu'on raconte une histoire et en
fait on peut aussi brouiller les cartes
parce que de l'autre côté ça devient sas
d'être possible de faire facilement la
différence entre ce qui relève du monde
réel et ce qui relève du monde
fictionnel inventé par les auteurs alors
là bas alors là on va revenir dans le
paf fictionnel une question de bruno
allain paris 2e une question qui
s'adresse peut-être plus
au
jedi
de notre plateau quelle est la place des
technologies de capture c'est pour ça
que ça y va fort dans laquelle la place
des technologies de capture de dioxyde
de carbone à long terme dans la lutte
contre les rejets de gaz à effet de
serre je répète la question peut
paraître un peu abstraite non mais pour
quelle est la place des technologies de
capture de technologie de capture de
d'oxydé de carbone à long terme dans la
lutte contre les rejets de gaz à effet
de serre alors la nature a mis au point
une technologie de capture du gaz
carbonique ou du dioxyde de carbone qui
est très efficace qui s'appelle les
plantes
puisque les plantes c'est comme ça
qu'elles se nourrissent enfin c'est
entre autres comme ça qu'elles se
nourrissent elles vont chercher le
carbone qui leur sert à faire les
molécules qui sont constitutives de
leurs feuilles de leur tronc et c'est
dans l'atmosphère dans le co2 justement
et cette molécule de co2 qu'elle trouve
dans l'atmosphère elle la casse en deux
avec l'aide de l'énergie du soleil c'est
ce qu'on appelle la photosynthèse et
elle se garde le carbone et laurent
d'oxygène ce qui est quand même bien
sympa de leur part alors ce processus là
et c'est celui qui fonctionne le mieux à
large échelle par contre quand on est
très nombreux sur terre on l'empêchent
de fonctionner correctement parce que on
coupe des forêts pour faire des surfaces
agricoles de la place donc en fait on
diminue la pompe à carbone parce qu'on
est nombreux et que on fait plein de
chant pour manger et plus on mange de
viande et plus on a besoin de beaucoup
de champs pour nourrir les animaux qu'on
va manger ensuite le
il ya des gens qui pensent qu'on peut
remplacer les arbres par des
technologies article pas par des objets
artificiels les machines dont l'espèce
d'aspirateurs ar donc machine aspire
vers et elle traite l'air pour en sortir
le co2 et elle rend généreusement le
reste de l'air à l'atmosphère alors
malheureusement c'est des processus qui
sont pas efficaces du tout la raison à
cela c'est que le co2 dans l'air il est
diluée il représente 0 04 % de l'air ça
fait pas beaucoup hein la deuxième chose
qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que le
co2 est une molécule totalement inerte
c'est bien pour ça que les plantes ont
besoin de l'énergie du soleil pour la
casser en deux si on a pas d'énergie on
casse pas ça en deux et donc la machine
qui veut faire la même chose que la
plante a aussi besoin d'énergie
et un petit calcul montre que si on
voulait avec ce genre de dispositif
compenser les émissions actuelles de co2
de l'humanité il faudrait six fois la
production électrique mondiale ryan pour
alimenter ce genre de dispositif de
capture voilà donc en ce moment on en
fera quelques uns pour amuser la galerie
donc on en a fait un en islande là c'est
peut-être celui que trop dieter a vu
passer dans la presse c'est
malheureusement c'est de l'ordre du
gadget alors je vais passer à une
question qui nous vient d'angers de gaël
rabillon galère à billom dans le danger
qui alors c'est une question qui sera
pour vous deux et on devra
malheureusement conclure par dans les
questions adhérents et adhérentes
croyez vous encore en la capacité de
l'homme à revenir à une consommation
plus raisonnable la consommation qui
venait donc aussi et blanc d'énergie
croyez vous encore en la capacité de
l'homme pour revenir à une consommation
plus raisonnable
si le s'il n'est pas raisonnable toute
façon il sera contraint de le faire
j'ai appris le court je me suis permis
en tant que près de roanne maintenant je
laisse la parole à jean-marc c'est un
peu le une question qu'on pose à la fin
du livre à la fin du livre on fait
intervenir un personnage
qui parle d'un mot barbare qui s'appelle
le striatum alors on sait pas et
duracell nous intéresse pas tellement de
savoir si effectivement leur style at
home et une cellule est une rupture
cérébrale ça nous intéresse pas
tellement de savoir s'il a tort ou
raison sur le plan biologique on s'en
fiche un peu par contre ils rappellent
un certain nombre de traits de
comportement des animaux que nous sommes
et il rappelle que malgré notre beau
cortex qui nous a permis de faire les
rencontres de la fnac des caméras des
écrans et des camions pour distribuer
nos livres on reste quand même
fondamentalement piloté par nos désirs
et nos désirs ils n'ont pas beaucoup de
[ __ ] de frein c'est à dire que quand
y'en a plus y'en a encore ou plus
exactement quand il y en a plus c'est à
dire beaucoup plus bas il ya encore de
la place pour qui on est encore plus
voilà et c'est clair que ça va nous
demain c'est probablement une des
difficultés majeures du défi auquel nous
sommes confrontés c'est de savoir
accepter des limites et d'accepter
l'idée que la technologie ne permettra
pas de les repousser indéfiniment donc
là ça fait quand même deux siècles qu'on
est très habitué à l'idée que la
technologie permet de repousser
n'importe quelle limite est en fait la
solution aux problèmes que nos qu'elle
nous sommes confrontés elle est beaucoup
moins dans les mains des ingénieurs
que dans les mains de je ne sais pas qui
qui pourraient faire en sorte que
collectivement ça nous pose pas plus de
problèmes que ça d'accepter des limites
alors injustes a ajouté que le
personnage dont parle jean marc à la fin
du livre existe réellement et qui
s'appelle sébastien bauler il est écrit
ah oui oui de la puissance est consacrée
à la question si le bug humains qu'ils
soient là je vois la russie robert
laffont un concert on s'est appuyé sur
ses sur ces essais on l'a rencontré
jean-marc l'a rencontré et il a une
façon de présenter lui aussi qui est
très ludique et très imagée et qui nous
a qui nous a séduits et on le fait
intervenir dans le livre parce que
justement il y rencontre seul entre nos
désirs et notre façon de fonctionner on
est programmé en fait pour être toujours
en expansion on est des animaux comment
tu dis accumulatif et opportuniste
accumulatif et opportuniste et on doit
en même temps on a on est capable de
réfléchir et de se projeter dans
l'avenir et c'est de ces deux aspects de
notre cerveau rentre parfois en
conflit parce qu'on sait très bien qu'on
risque on en veut toujours plus et on
peut pas s'empêcher on a du mal à
s'empêcher de l'avoir et en même temps
on sait qu'on prend un énorme risque
dans le futur en continuant de cette
manière là alors avant de passer au coup
de coeur qui sera la toute dernière
partie courte on va passer un coup de
projecteur puisque si on a l'habitude de
demander dans cette sécession artiste
engagé à chacun chacune de nos invités
de mettre en avant justement une
structure une association j'ai commencé
par cette crise sur 20 que vous avez
choisi vous de mettre en avant qui
s'appelle un enfant un avenir je crois
que c'est une association qui parrainait
par l'explorateur jean louis etienne si
j'ai bien compris est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en parler pourquoi vous avez choisi
de la langue tout simplement je n'ai pas
parce que j'ai participé puis elle et
elle et
cgg rencontrer ces des enfants qui sont
malades ou
hospitalisés et à qui on apporte un
soutien en formule en leur faisant faire
tout un tas d'activités qui sont
généralement liés à la mer puisque le
président est un est un est un ancien
marin de la marine nationale est
d'ailleurs que j'ai rencontrés sur un
bateau comme moi même j'étais mal et
qu'il ya un qui est un type
extraordinaire et qui voilà qui aide les
enfants et moi j'ai été j'ai rencontré
j'étais enfant j'étais rencontrer ces
enfants j'ai fait partie de rencontre
j'aurais fait des dessins j'ai beaucoup
parlé avec eux j'ai regardé l'heure des
singes et c'est une association qui est
très très vivante avec des gens qui
m'ont j'ai trouvé vraiment
extraordinaire quoi qui se donnait à
fond à fond là-dedans et les enfants
savaient vraiment l'air de leur faire
quelque chose quoi ça marchait vraiment
très très bien c'est une petite
association mais qui est très
très vivante et très très efficace et
qui est basée à brest et le site
internet c'est les tirets enfants ou
plurielle tirait à venir au singulier
point commun les mains tirait enfants au
pluriel tirait à venir singulier points
comme de votre côté jean marc jancovici
vous avez choisi de simplement devait
être en projet en
un coup de projecteur sur votre
association la vôtre et celle d'autres
personnes aussi un volet du thriller the
shift project alors racontez nous alors
je vais vous faire une confidence en
fait je n'aime pas tellement ce genre de
question parce que je trouve que ça
dévalorise inutilement les gens qu'on ne
cite pas je veux dire par là choisir une
association vous savez il ya plein de
gens partout qui font des trucs
absolument remarquable et donc je me dis
toujours de quel droit est ce qu'on
considère que ça c'est plus remarquable
que le reste alors monsieur dubois tant
qu'à faire je vais pas je vais parler de
la vienne
alors pourquoi est-ce que je parle de la
mienne pour deux raisons la première
c'est que la mise en avant médiatique a
un côté très cruel pour les gens qui
restent dans l'ombre c'est qu'en général
les gens qu'on met en avant ne serait
rien sans la structure qui déporte donc
c'est mon cas il se trouve que
l'essentiel des choses que je sais je
les ai pas inventés je les ai apprises
moi même d'autres donc j'ai été et je
continue à être le padawan de beaucoup
beaucoup de gens donc ce qui permet de
nourrir par exemple ce livre c'est pour
partie des calculs que je n'ai pas fait
des recherches que je n'ai pas fait des
raisonnements que je n'ai pas tenu et
simplement qu'ils ont été servis par
d'autres personnes qui ont travaillé
avant voilà donc c'est une façon de
rappeler que derrière tout derrière tout
combat si on peut utiliser ce mot qui
semble être l'oeuvre d'un individu en
fait il ya toujours beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qui travaillent et en ce moment au
chiffre de projets qu'il ya énormément
de gens qui travaillent alors là pour le
coup de façon délibérée mais ça sera
l'occasion d'en parler à d'autres
moments
pour l'échéance présidentielle qui se
dessine et voilà donc tant qu'à faire
autant dire que se livrent leur doit
aussi quelque chose ça a été créé qu'en
cette année 2010 2007 a conquis à lyon
11 on va passer maintenant au coup de
coeur donc ses coups de coeur culturel
de deux de nos invités
alors on va commencer par là par la
musique jean marc jean marc jancovici
vous avez choisi vous c'est un single
que vous avez choisi
walking in the air de nightwish oui
alors j'aurais pu choisir c'est pareil
je dois avoir dix mille titres sur mon
ordinateur
et en fonction des circonstances je peux
écouter n'importe quoi du classique au
heavy metal donc alors j'aime bien la
mélodie de cette chanson et je laime
bien parce que c'est un groupe que m'ont
fait découvrir des filles
donc voilà donc c'est aussi pour ça que
je l'aimé bien voilà
le coup de coeur musical aura pile poil
20h vous allez dire christophe blain
vous c'est mort prématurée la c1 c'est
une commune oui c'est un concept c'est
une oeuvre de
arthur ashe où il mort prématurée d'un
chanteur populaire dans la force de
l'âge c'est sa mort oui là le titre et
louis marc
oui
c'est un lien avec avec le monde sans
faim parce que il ya un moment l'aîné le
travail était tellement intense
que j'étais obligé de prendre du recul
et il se trouve que arthur ashe m'a
demandé de faire le clip d'une chanson
et j'aime arthur ashe depuis ses débuts
je le suis depuis ses débuts j'étais
voit plein de fois en concert ça c'est
un artiste que j'adore et je dis oui et
j'ai fait son clip j'ai réalisé son clip
avec
avec un animateur extraordinaire qui
s'appelle jean mathieu tanguay et on a
travaillé tous les deux pendant quatre
mois je me suis interrompue du livre
pour pouvoir retrouver de la fraîcheur
et travailler sur complètement autre
chose mais c'était il y avait des comme
le livre a quelque chose de très
onirique aussi il ya des personnages qui
a pas il ya mère nature qui apparaît
qu'un personnage onirique et qui nous
parle qui est une incarné par une femme
géante j'ai cotisé aussi une très longue
voila voila j'ai utilisé aussi une femme
géante dans son dans ce clip il ya des
choses qui se disent eux qui se
croisaient et
et voilà ça m'a permis de prendre une
grande respiration et j'adore la chanson
du clip j'adore l'album j'adore la
chanson du clip qui s'appelle
l'avalanche sur laquelle on a travaillé
pendant quatre mois on était huit avec
des des animateurs des décorateurs des
gens qui ont fait le compositing qu'ils
étaient tous extraordinaires c'est un
travail qui m'a permis de me ressourcer
et je suis retourné ensuite sur le livre
avec d'autant plus d'énergie alors va t
on va rester avec vous pour ce qui
concerne le coup de coeur
cinématographiques c'est un film de
sydney pollack que vous avez choisi
c'était et c'est toujours le cavalier
électrique réalisé en 1979 avec entre
autres jane fonda et robert redford oui
parce que c'est un film incroyablement
sympathique et
touchant avec des images qui sont très
très belle et qui sont qui montrent
qu'ils ont quelque chose de
bien quelque chose d' iron man c'est un
personnage très politique était un
ancien champion de rodéo qui qui en fait
ne fait plus que de la publicité pour
des céréales il apparaît avec son cheval
éventuellement à las vegas et il a un
costume de cowboy assez flambeaux et un
vilain costumes lumineux en fait il a
des petits guirlandes sur lui il est
très kitsch très fanci comme ça et un
jour il est le cheval sur lucky luke qui
monte pour un peu il devient le call it
parce que ce cette villa ne
l'intéressent plus elle est triste et
las vegas est une ville incroyablement
triste et il décide le cheval qui est un
super cheval sur lequel il doit
apparaître une fois à las vegas et
drogué et il ne supporte pas cette
situation là pour qu'ils restent calmes
ils fuient ils passent les tables de jeu
et il fuit dans la nuit de las vegas qui
est lui une lumineuse du strip et quand
ils dépassent le strip il s'éteint il
disparaît dans la nuit son costume c'est
un
il disparaît dans la nuit du désert elle
cette image est très très belle et j'ai
revu le film en faisant le livre elle
est en lien avec avec le livre elle dit
quelque chose de notre monde et
notamment à las vegas c'est vraiment la
représentation ultime de des excès du
monde du monde occidental et ce cavalier
électrique à quelque chose qui est
une très belle fable avec une histoire
d'amour adultes mais qui est très très
touchante entre jane fonda et ce et
robert redford qui incarne le personnage
principal et qui est une fable
écologique a c'est vraiment très très
belle équipe oui j'aurais pu faire
apparaître un cavalier électrique un
moment dans le dans le monde sans fin et
c'est peut-être une aura dans une
traduction une version future avec donc
jean marc jancovici envierges puisque
tout d'abord il a regardé il ya une
large mesure à cheval voilà alors
revendre à des modifications en ce qui
me concerne
pour votre coup de coeur
cinématographiques
jean marc jancovici vous ça nous ramène
aux préoccupations aussi de l' ouvrage
puisque ces 2 le film qui avait fort
heureusement pour sa beauté fort
malheureusement pour l'urgence de ce
qu'ils disaient fait beaucoup parler de
lui c'était le film de jacques perrin en
2009 océans au pluriel oui alors c'est
un film que je trouve très poétique très
joli
il est à la fois frappants par les
images il est directement en lien avec
avec le thème le thème contre est là
et c'est
enfin c'est un film qui maquille map
que j'ai que j'avais vu sur très grand
écran
et donc c'était d'autant plus magnifique
parce que les images sont absolument
soit absolument splendide et puis la
voix de jacques perrin est là quelque
chose d'extraordinairement apaisant
pour parler de quelque chose
d'extraordinairement angoissant c'est
vrai qu'avoir un peu le trouve
exactement il ya cette espèce de
décalage entre cette voie vous savez
c'est cette voie de grand-père compteur
qui s'apprête à vous endormir là quand
vous êtes gamin et puis un film qui vous
dit quand même qu'on est en train de
faire n'importe quoi qui est en train de
se passer des choses qui est qu'on est
en train quelque part de gâcher une
merveille voilà et donc j'ai pensé parce
que il ya un lien avec
il ya un lien direct avec avec cet
ouvrage dans ce contraste encore une
fois entre quelque chose de merveilleux
et quelque chose de jeu pas quels mots
je dois utiliser de détestable
d'angoissant
2 enfin voilà de pas sympathique quoi
restons avec vous jean marc jancovici
pour ce qui est du coup de coeur et ce
sera le dernier des trois
en termes de littérature alors vous
c'est pas un roman en particulier pour
le coup c'est une oeuvre puisque c'est
un cycle le cycle en question ces
fortunes de france fortune au singulier
de robert merle qui est une fresque qui
a été écrite et publiée entre 1977 et
2003 alors c'est un
cd livres que j'ai lus quand j'étais
jeune adulte
que j'avais trouvé très captivant c'est
à dire qu'à la fin de chaque tome on
avait envie de 1,10 m qu'est-ce qu'il
fiche là quand est ce qu'il va nous
sortir le suivant et puis c'était un
mariage que j'avais trouvé très
intéressant entre
l'histoire
l'histoire m'a toujours intéressée et en
même temps son enseignement je les ai
toujours trouvé monstrueusement
rébarbatif et donc là on parlait tout à
l'heure de pourquoi pas de faire un
roman bas là en l'occurrence c'est la
façon qu'avait trouvé merle de nous
intéresser à l'histoire de notre pays au
travers d'un de quelque chose qui
présente tous les canons de la
littérature sympathique donc on a
vraiment envie de lire voilà donc ctcc
ainsi un genre que j'avais beaucoup aimé
et une lecture que à laquelle j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir parce qu'on va
signer que le récit ce que ça raconte ce
que ces treize volumes raconte se
déroule entre 1547 et 1661 pour situer
qui était robert merle prix goncourt
1949 j'en parle parce qu'on est aussi
dans une saison des prix littéraires la
prix goncourt 1949 pour le week end à
zuydcoote que henri verneuil a ensuite
adapté au cinéma et les personnes de ma
génération la grosse quarantaine on l'on
lui aussi à l'école puisqu'il avait
aussi écrit la mort est mon métier
ab-so-lu-ment adapté des mémoires qui
vient en danger cités dans un genre très
différent je crois qu'on a eu à peu près
tout merde donc
et on finira avec bastien ça va nous
ramener aussi quelque part à l'histoire
parce que c'est une historienne que vous
avez choisi de mettre en projecteurs
christophe blain vous quand on vous a
demandé paris un coup de coeur
littéraire vous n'avez pas dit un livre
j'avais toute l'oeuvre d'arlette farge
oui parce que déjà la cas l'histoire est
passionnante j'ai eu la chance de la
rencontrer
parce que j'ai créé
mes séries qui s'appelle isaac le pirate
se passe au xviiie siècle et j'ai
rencontré cadet a valu le première de
vaud distinction à voilà et arlette
farge est une grande spécialiste de la
de la vie au xviiie siècle de l'avis de
la population pas seulement la vie des
raconte souvent à travers la vie des
aristocrates la vie du roi l'avis de la
cour est elle raconte aussi beaucoup la
vie du peuple elle a une façon de le
raconter dans tous ces ouvrages qu
absolument
passionnant elle écrit très très bien et
elle cite les documents d'époque qui ont
un côté moi j'adore la langue du xviiie
siècle et qui est fascinant le mélange
de son écriture à elle qui est très qui
est très belle très vivante très
littéraire mais très fluide elle cite
elle cite les documents mais les blés
les comptes rendus de police de l'époque
avec le les préoccupations des nous met
au coeur des préoccupations quotidiennes
des gens la façon dont ils vivaient dans
les rues dans les campagnes et surtout
beaucoup dans les rues parce que moi
évidemment je suis intéressé par la vie
parisienne puisque c'est là que se passe
mon mon histoire et
c'est une femme délicieuse et
passionnante elle faisait l a fait je
crois qu'elle n'en fait plus maintenant
elle faisait beaucoup de radios aussi
elle avait des émissions sur france
culture et je trouve que ces bouquins
sont les dévore ils sont étonnants
totalement étonnant parce qu il nous
plonge dans une vraie machine à remonter
le temps et avec des choses qu'on a
qu'on n'a pas idée de la façon dont
vivaient les gens au quotidien avec des
choses très très précise mais qui était
très importante qui semblent
anecdotiques comme ça mais c'est les
gens vivent avec ça en permanence il
avait une autre vie elle sait
parfaitement nous plonger là dedans
c'est des lectures vraiment celle là
c'est vraiment pas l'histoire du tout
ennuyeuse les chercher où je l étais
chercheuse au cnrs mais eh bien c'est
sur ces conseils est ce qui nous
renseigne aussi nous sur ce qui vous
nourrit les saillies ce chercheur
l'illustrateur c'est toujours bien de
savoir qu'est ce qui nourrit justement
ce qui a donné donc 7 à
on ne peut que le conseiller lesur
conseiller parce que c'est à lire à
transmettre art picorer parce que c'est
plein de deux chapitres et de micros
chapitre avec encore une fois un des
personnages c'est dame nature une grande
belle géante à la chevelure rousse très
troublante il ya donc le fameux iron man
et il ya donc vous deux messieurs
puisque vous êtes aussi des personnages
narrateur de ce livre qui paraît donc
après demain le 29 octobre aux éditions
dargaud le monde sans fin il y avait le
gault et millau il y avait le lagarde et
michard il y a toujours le gault et
millau il ya toujours le lagarde et
michard mais ça m'a fait sourire quand
j'ai vu la couverture brulin fois parce
que ya pas de prénom sur la couverture
c'est ya le genre maintenant il y aura
le blin jancovici tout le temps mais
visible après le lagarde et michard et
le gault et millau cette saison deux
prix littéraires vous le jancovici ben
la voilà comme ça aussi qu'on devient un
mythe messieurs c'est en devenant juste
un nom et est un symbole voilà c'est
donc ça paraît chez dargaud le 29
octobre merci à vous deux vous pourrez
donc après nous avoir suivis en direct
dès 20h on rend l'antenne
retrouver cette session en replay comme
toutes les autres sessions que nous
avons fait
avec la fnac sur l'éclaireur point
fnac.com l'éclaireur sans l'apostrophent
l'éclaireur au singulier l'éclaireur
point fnac.com où vous pourrez donc
retrouver cette session avec jean marc
jancovici et christophe blain et toutes
les autres merci à vous toutes et tous
et bonne soirée
[Musique]